evidence about the safety and
effectiveness of covet-19 vaccination
during pregnancy has been growing and
here to tell us more is women's health
service physician dr nica vascara from
intermountain health care the sponsors
of the cell segment welcome dr vascara
thank you for being here so many
questions about pregnancy and
vaccinations can you what can you tell
me are you seeing a difference in covent
infection rates between vaccinated and
unvaccinated women
yes well firstly thank you so much for
having me here i'm very excited to be
here to talk about this important topic
today
regarding your question there absolutely
is a difference
especially when we're talking about code
infection with um that leads to in-house
our hospitalization and icu admission we
actually have seen through the cdc cases
reported that symptomatic patients with
coven-19 infections who are pregnant
have a three-fold increase in
risk of
intensive care unit admission or icu
admission which includes ventilation
support as well as a 70 increased risk
of
death when compared to non-pregnant
patients now i know a lot of women are
very concerned especially in that first
trimester
of just doing everything right because
you know that's a very cautious time for
a lot of women is it better to perhaps
wait until the second trimester or to
get a vaccination if that's something
you're interested in or
should you just do it as soon as you can
that's a really excellent question so
basically through all of the evidence
regarding the safety and effectiveness
of vaccines of covered vaccine
specifically in pregnancy
we found that the
the
the known benefits of vaccination in
pregnancy far outweigh the potential
risks of vaccination and pregnancy so we
recommend it
and we recommend the primary treatment
or primary vaccination in all stages of
pregnancy let's talk about boosters the
big topic of conversation right now a
lot of people are looking to get their
booster shots for pregnant women same
thing should they
should they wait until they feel like
they're in a safe zone or just as soon
as you're eligible for it go for it i
would say just as soon as you're
eligible go for it
the boosters are just as safe and
effective and also
just even just even past the known
regular complications of covid19 like
the icu admission like i mentioned
before there's also pregnancy-related
complications that are increased with
infection and those things are like
hypertensive um disorders of pregnancy
such as preeclampsia as well as preterm
birth
neonatal or newborn admission into the
neonatal icu because of covid19
infection and stillbirth that is some
really good
information i think the bottom line is
there are a lot more benefits to getting
the vaccine than they're than not
getting it thank you for your time and
thank you to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring this segment for more
information visit
intermountainhealthcare.org
forward slash nevada jillian